everything's gone yeah
the backside's already caved in
wow
okay we're ready okay all right so you
know
first and last name of your title for us
it's tim symansky s-z-y-m-a-n-s-k-i
las vegas fire and rescue all right so
tell me what happened or what is
happening here so this is the vacant
silverstone country club clubhouse
we received a 9-1-1 call at 12 30
that the building was on fire when we
got here there was heavy fire on the
back side of the building
it got up into the area up into the top
we were worried about the
possible collapse
so we didn't put any firefighters from
the inside we had to fight this fire
from the outside it's pretty stubborn
again it was always the fear we've had
two previous fires here so we didn't
know what the integrity of the building
was
we didn't want to risk any firefighters
lives going inside there so we stayed on
the defensive mode it did spread
throughout the rest of the building
because we are fighting it
from the outside generally when we have
a building fire we go into the inside
where the base of the fire is
but because of the potential for
collapse we didn't want to risk
anybody's life
we could see through the inside there it
didn't appear there was anybody inside
the building
so we just bought it defensively
it's uh coming up on six o'clock we're
still
here we've got it surrounded it's not
going to spread to anything
cause of the fire will not be determined
until the fire is completely out it's
pretty well destroyed at this point
after six hours of
trying to put it out
so a lot of neighbors were talking about
issues with squatters at this location
those previous fires were those caused
by squatters or do
we don't know
i'd have to go back and look up the
records
in that but uh there is some evidence
that there's
possibly some squatters in here we also
heard that
it was uh
frequented by
uh kids from the area because there's a
big parking lot here
that hang out
um
we don't know at this point all that
we're concerned about is to put the fire
out definitely so that appears to be
like you said the strategy kind of just
making sure it doesn't spread at this
point right as it kind of burns down
well we're trying to keep it under
control it's not going to go anywhere
it's uh it's all vacant all the way
around it's just just a lot
but we're still putting water on it we'd
like to put it out we've got a lot of
water going on it but it's still burning
and i know in terms of like you said you
don't know for sure if this was a
slaughter situation that started this
but i personally have covered a lot of
fires in las vegas that were started by
fire so that is a pretty
relevant issue right in vega buildings
yeah we've
lately here in the city we've been
pretty fortunate we've not had a lot of
them lately this is actually the first
big fire that we've had in quite a while
and so again
a lot of squatter fires again are not
intentional they're accidental either
due to smoking or
cooking or something along that nature
at this fire we really don't have any
idea of what started this fire do an
estimated damage amount not now
we were talking about it
uh it's going to be a total loss
i would have to talk to the
investigators on it figured it's too
early anything else no nobody's hurt and
that's the main thing that's our main
objective is to
make sure that nobody gets hurt there is
nothing here
worth anybody getting hurt over or
killed
we've got that taken care of and now
we're just gonna stay here until it's
completely out and it's we're probably
going to be here till brick day break at
least wow okay
thank you
is this good practice for some of you
you're going to guys on fast not really
because all we're doing is just lobbing
a lot of water onto it right now as you
can see we got
pretty well everybody back away from the
building because we're afraid that
anyone that what holds the walls up is
the roof and as you can see the roof is
deteriorated it's going to go so we want
to make sure that everybody is outside
the collapse zone
because that's what kills a lot of
firefighters is the building coming down
it's silent you don't know it's not
worth it we haven't lost anything right
now in the way of injuries or fatalities
we don't want to go there so we're
keeping everybody back
and we're just lobbing water from what
we call master streams the ground
streams and the ladder trucks because we
don't want any firefighters close to
that building absolutely i mean do you
fight a vacant fire
differently
did you fight an occupied structure is
it all the same
now usually in the smaller buildings
we'll we'll change operations we'll go
from defensive to what we call offensive
where we're going to go in there and get
to the seat of the fire we want to be in
charge of it
but we were never able to get to that
point here this fire was always in
charge and we went on the defense and
that means we didn't want it to get out
and around out of the area and we didn't
want to risk anybody's life at the same
time
do you know if they had utilities power
gas or anything like that or they're all
set off no all the utilities are off to
the building okay
that's gonna give you an indication
right there i mean if there's no
utilities in there does that steer your
investigators
towards
one way the other or no well i i mean
we're going to rule out
utilities and then let's just say that
squatters were in a building and let's
just say that we
caught up with a squatter
when you have arson
you have to prove intent
which means that they intentionally
wanted to burn down the building but
let's just say they were in the building
and they admitted and they says well i
was cooking a steak or i fell asleep in
my sleeping bag caught fire because i
was smoking
that's they weren't intentionally trying
to burn the building down so many times
people ask well why didn't you charge
that
person with
arson it's because they didn't
intentionally try to burn the building
down
worst case scenario
is you could charge them with trespass
because they don't have permission to be
there
and then that's something that they have
to work out with the people that own the
building but you have to have
intent and we have to be able to prove
it if there that there is a tent even if
they come up and tell us that they did
it we have to we have to find that
evidence that makes sense
awesome thank you so much
okay
and i've got this on our facebook live